so Superboy Prime had one of the most
insane moments in the history of DC
Comics check this out so Superboy Prime
basically shows up on the scene in DC
and he's pissed off because the
superheroes aren't superheroes anymore
they're all basically anti-heroes beyond
that there's another super boy who
showed up named Connor Kent and super
white primes pissed off because he feels
like he's been replaced so he starts
beating the hell out of Conor Kent and
not even by a little bit he's absolutely
demolishing this guy so the rest of all
these different teenage superhero teams
show up Young Justice and the Teen
Titans and so on and so forth and what
follows is one of the most spectacular
flippings of the history of DC Comics
super boys ripping people's arms off
he's beating them to death I mean he's
just demolishing everybody right he's
like come come come fail me and just
crushes these teams they don't even have
a chance in the end it takes the flashes
snatching this guy up and running him
into the speed force and trying to lock
him away crazy enough he ultimately
finds a way to escape and then he comes
back make sure you follow for more